and
hey guys p peppers here this is my game
of thrones season 6 episode 10 recap it
is the season finale of season six and I
just want to say before I get started
that this is going to be from my
perspective as a fan of the show I'm not
going to spend a lot of time picking
apart the story or you know how it
relates to the books which I love as
well but you know there's plenty of
videos are going to be like that and I
would be willing to do a Q&A if you have
questions about the storylines and
things like that but for this this is
just going to be as a fan of the show
because it was a fun episode to watch
and I'm not going to think too hard
about that so let's get started in
King's Landing everyone's getting ready
for the trial the big takeaway from this
was that Searcy probably had something
up her sleeve she doesn't seem that
worried I thought it was an interesting
scene when she was getting dressed she's
wearing a black gown and it kind of
reminded me of whenever Tywin became the
hand and just that whole connection she
has with her father of you know wanting
to be strong like him and that whole
idea you know if I was not if I was just
a man if I'd have been born a man things
would be so much different I would be
running things and Tommen is you know
his character seems to be really
completely lost like stuck in this hard
place between his wife and his mother
the Great's up to Baylor we go right to
it with lorises trial he is you know in
custody so they bring him out and
everyone is in attendance including
Kevan Lannister the hand of the king and
mace Tyrell who is lorises father
soloist explains that he doesn't need a
trial because he's willing to confess
which the high Sparrow accepts and he
explains to him that he
he loses his chance to inherit and
become the Lord of Highgarden and
everything else that goes along with
that then they decide to give him a
seven-pointed star in his forehead
around the same time Tommen gets ready
to attend and zombie Mountain shows up
to stop him and keep him in his chamber
so at the trial everyone's starting to
wonder what's going on most of all
Marjorie and the high Sparrow isn't
tripping he figures everything's going
to work out the gods will have their
justice and things will be fine anyways
he sends lancel and a small group to go
collect Cersei just in case on the way
out Lin cell notices this little kid and
he decides to follow him that takes him
into the area that's underground below
the set so we also get to find out where
pycelle was going he followed a
different little bird when he was
leaving his chamber and he ends up
downstairs in the dungeons with Kai
burned car burns waiting there for him
and he explains to him even though he
doesn't hate him he has no ill will he
needs him to go and if you're wondering
why that is it's because pycelle is on
the small Council and they need to get
rid of all the members in order to
achieve a transfer of power so high
style gets stabbed to death by the
little birds and got to give him credit
at least he got in one shot before it
was all said and done so Lance aw gets
himself stabbed and we realized that he
is downstairs in the area where the Mad
King had stashed all that wildfire from
brands visions he he realizes this too
and as far as the wildfire scene goes I
think we just need to watch it again
so take that King's Landing I was I was
hoping that this would happen and you
know it was a pretty awesome scene
Cersei destroys all of her immediate
enemies in an instant and shockingly
Tommen doesn't die as collateral damage
Cersei continues to rampage and she has
septa you nella and she basically water
boards or with some wine tells her why
she does what she does it's basically
because she enjoys it and then she gives
her to the mountain this is a you know I
mean it's just an example of I guess the
depravity that that seriously has
reached I you know I don't know what
else to say so I'll just leave it at
that so we cut back to Tommen and look
he's still alive can you believe he's
still alive ask your friends in the room
I can't believe Tom and made it out
alive anyways he's looking over the
carnage and he's still alive it's a big
surprise but then he sort of takes off
his crown walks off screen and yeah he
jumps out the window and well rest in
peace Tommen look at her the twins in
welder and Jamie have sort of a heated
conversation they exchanged a bunch of
japes Jamie calls him out for not really
being a lawyer and Walter points out
that hey you know the point of fighting
is to defeat your enemies and Jamie
counters that with the fact that Walter
is pretty much useless and they had to
use the Lannisters and you know so on
and so forth so Sam well actually makes
it to old town which is pretty exciting
because in the books this is something
that's something I'm waiting to find out
what's going to happen although you know
i'm going to book nerd out a little bit
here they took out some major stuff like
part of most of the reasons why it is
interesting is all related to characters
are on show but anyways we you know we
there's a little funny scene where
you know he talks to the guy and they
don't know why is there and then we get
to see this cool ass scene of the
library and it and you know like even if
it doesn't leave you know live up to
what it was in the books there's still a
lot of potential here for the show in
the North Melisandre gets called out for
burnin Shireen at the stake Davos is
pissed and he wants John to kill her or
he wants to kill her himself its he
wants something to happen that involves
Melisandre getting killed and Melisandre
argues that she has been ready to die
for several years if the Lord of Light
was done with her but he is not and she
could really help out and John just sort
of splits the difference and sends her
away I think it's important to remember
that they showed us in the first episode
of the season I think it was that she's
just wearing a glamour that makes her
look like she does so you know she could
definitely just go around the corner
take off for choker be the old woman and
still be around you know I mean I don't
think this is the end of her involvement
and you know I mean she brought John
back from from the dead so she's still
going to be an important character in
one way or another John and Sansa
basically make up they have a
conversation about they need to trust
each other and they both apologize for
not doing so and they talk about like
who's in charge John says i'm not a
stark and Santa says you are to me he
also brings up the idea about trusting
little finger and she makes it pretty
clear that she knows that no one should
trust little finger which is good and
they have a pretty cool scene I I
thought it was was all right you know
she says that the white raven came and
winter is here and he mentions you know
well father always said it was coming
and they both smile and I don't know I
mean you have to be pretty pretty jaded
if you didn't enjoy that as you know as
far as how the TV series has played out
we get some Dorne um lady Alana queen of
thorns is there she's meeting with
sands sand snakes who basically I guess
are in charge but yeah she's she's
complaining she's upset she has a lot of
reasons to be and we find out Varys is
there and so basically long story short
on door and it looks like they're just
going to be on Danny side speaking of
Danny she's in murine getting ready to
leave and she has to break up with Dario
first her paramour if you're if you're
wondering like if he's important or not
I mean he in both the books and the show
she really does care about him and more
so in the books you know she's that's
pretty much her thing is is Dario I mean
she gets married to other people and
whatnot but she does actually prefer him
as her lover so tyrion tries to comfort
her consoler whatever you want to say
about the situation and she basically
points out that he's not very good at
that but she doesn't need him for that
and she goes ahead and makes him hand of
the Queen and it's actually not a bad
choice even though she doesn't really
know much about it he was a good hand of
the King in the books and even though
show didn't go into it that much it is a
good choice also I think what was
interesting about that conversation was
you know he put you just basically lays
it out you have everything you wanted
you got your ships you got your army you
got your dragons let's go do this thing
so let me get some Freight pie if you're
not familiar with the fray pie theory it
was basically on different characters
the manderley supposedly you know killed
some phrase and fed them to some other
phrase but in the show this is the
show's version of it and we see that we
got this new character here but oh wait
it's not actually a new character it's
actually Arya and she's wearing a face
and you know she's basically become a
faceless man and she proceeds to kill
Walter frana you know I actually
mentioned this in my preview for this
seat for this episode that I thought
this was going to happen based on the
way that the show
I'd been you know doing it storylines
and I was I was satisfied to see it I
mean obviously there's some problems and
how this would all go down but hey
Walder Frey is dead and arias back in
Westeros so it's all all right with me
we get a little exchange with sansom
little finger where he tells her his
dream is to be on the Iron Throne with
her by his side then he tries to kiss
her where she and she shuts him down he
goes on to sort of threaten her and
point out you know what what what
happened and you know what he's done so
on and she basically says that she's not
she I mean she kind of indicates that
she's really not afraid of him but you
know there's obviously tension that's
going to be there from from now on
through the rest of their relationship
we make it beyond the wall and we find
Benjen and brand parting ways benjin
explains that he can't go south of the
wall but it's time for brand to do that
and it looks like they end up in the
weirwoods where John took his bow and
benjin says he'll still fight for the
the living but he just can't go along
with them so Brian decides to hook up
with the weirwood tree and he decides to
also pay off the thing that everybody's
been waiting for and that is Jon Snow's
parentage we see him outside the tower
of joy follow Ned up the stairs and he
finds his sister Liana in bed and she's
really happy to see him problem is she's
dying she just gave birth and she's
going to die as a result so there's a
little bit of time where he tries to you
know give her some hope and she
basically says now that's not important
and goes on to tell him who the baby is
so if you've never really paid attention
to theories and things like that this is
the r plus l equals J theory Rhaegar
Targaryen plus Lee
Anna stark equals Jon Snow if you're not
sure what that is just look it up our
plus l equals J and you'll find lots of
information she whispers in his ear you
can't exactly hear what she's saying she
says the baby's name she says that
Robert Baratheon who she was betrothed
to will kill him if he finds out and she
asked Ned to please take care of the
child so so basically net takes him back
in he calls him Jon Snow the name I
think that it probably is from what i've
read is it it's probably Joe Harris
which is another Targaryen King which I
won't go into right now but that would
be a good name and obviously net has to
change the name to protect him because
any Targaryen air would be a threat and
therefore couldn't be allowed to live so
if you're wondering if there's any
different interpretation of this I
really don't think so I mean I think
it's just saying that Jon Snow is a
Targaryen born from Liana stark and in
case you're wondering that makes
Denarius actually his aunt because
Rhaegar Targaryen was her oldest brother
so that was the big reveal right well
there's more John's in the north he's
got everybody together in the Great Hall
of Winterfell and they're kind of
discussing what what's going to happen
in a post Bolton world the Knights of
the Vale aren't feeling the wildlings
and the half of the people in this room
weren't on John side they actually you
know we're behind the bolton so nobody
really knows what's going to happen
they're trying to figure it out most of
the families just kind of want to go and
pretend like it never happened but for
the third episode in a row Liana Mormont
steps up to steal the show and she goes
ahead and basically calls everybody out
calls the other houses out for not
standing behind Winterfell and the
Starks and somewhat out of nowhere
crowns John the king of the north or at
least she declares that and everybody
sighs to go along with it now that is
the families that didn't go along with
him in the first place like the man
relieves the Glovers the sermons and
also the Knights of the Vale and the
only person that really seems to have a
problem with the whole situation is
little finger so we get back to King's
Landing Jamie came back to town to find
everything in chaos and so she basically
hatches a plan where she ends up taking
the Iron Throne now this is only really
a political situation you know she
basically was it you know did set this
up kai burn would be the hand everyone
else that could have a poster right away
immediately is dead so voila you're on
the throne that being said there really
is no one behind her so even though
she's there right now she'll have to
fight for anything that she wants to be
able I mean any chance of her being able
to keep it would be you know she's going
to have to do a little bit more than
just pronounced herself Queen Cersei
first of her name we end things out with
some pretty amazing looking scenes of
Danny and her fleet sailing towards
Westeros buries his back the first time
I watched it I didn't even notice that
he was there he was in Dorne and then he
was there but you know she's got her
dragon she's got her boats and she's on
her way so in closing so much stuff
happened so many different things got
paid off you know the show is not the
books and the books are not the show but
as far as things go this was a pretty
frigging amazing episode of the show is
I didn't want to nitpick and tear it
apart there's plenty of videos out there
i'm sure that will do that for you but
let's just enjoy for what it is it was
you know there was so many different
things you know i was i was looking
forward to seeing him some of my
predictions were going to come true and
like there were all of them did and then
there were ones i didn't even
fact like you know seriously taking the
throne and it was just it was surprising
to see all this stuff play out in the
same episode and yeah they're in a hurry
there's not much there's not many
episodes left after this but you know it
when I was watching it I was just I was
just really into it and you know I I
don't think that I I guess maybe I'm
it's not like I'm settling for it it's
not like but i have just sort of you
know tried to pay attention to what the
show is doing and enjoy it for being the
show and you know this episode i was i
was pretty excited about so i hope
you'll like the video and subscribe to
my channel i'll be making a few new ones
this week I've been working on season 7
predictions and waiting for the when's
the winner to come out the book so that
I can do some of the song of ice and
fire stuff and I hope that I'll have
probably like one or two per week in the
time in between now and next season so
i'll be talking to you too